the migrants have no Lobby only an
enlightened aroused and perhaps angered
public opinion can do anything about the
migrants
the people you have seen have the
strength to harvest your fruit and
vegetables
they do not have the strength to
influence legislation
maybe we do
good night and good luck
maybe we do that was CBS news anchor
Edward R Murrow concluding the 1960
documentary Harvest of Shame the
broadcast examined the plight of Migrant
Farm Workers in America by the end of
the decade president Lyndon Johnson's
war on poverty led to some help for
internet Farm Workers and their families
including one program that strives to
break the cycle of poverty through
education Omar via Franca has the story
let's let's get you out Giselle Chavez
is used to getting up before the sun
rises but today is different
she's packing pillows clothes and the
only life she's ever known in Edinburg
Texas into her mom's car
after one more family breakfast together
the daughter of Migrant workers will
drive 300 miles from the fields to her
freshman year in college at Saint
Edwards University in Austin I'm nervous
like oh my gosh like what's gonna happen
am I gonna like the classes am I gonna
like the people are they gonna like me
no
it's a long way from where Giselle spent
her summers at what her family calls the
Sandia the watermelon feels in Texas
where thousands of melons are picked
packed and shipped for sale across the
country giselle's job was to slap
stickers on the Watermelons only getting
a break every four hours if I sit down I
can't put all those stickers and they
want me to put all the stickers on each
watermelon and I can but
and I'm standing I'm putting my arms are
getting tired so I'm standing my feet
Giselle will now sit down in a classroom
to major in math thanks to Camp the
college assistance migrant Program Camp
helps migrant worker students fund their
first year in college the migrant Farm
worker occupies the lowest level of any
major group in the American economy the
life of Migrant workers was highlighted
in 1960 by legendary CBS news anchors
Edward R Murrow in a documentary called
Harvest of Shame Murrow gave viewers an
up close look at the poverty and poor
working conditions migrant workers faced
in the richest country in the world
because of a lack of access to education
approximately one out of every 500
children whose parents are still migrant
laborers finishes grade school
approximately one out of every five
thousand ever finishes high school and
there is no case upon the record of the
child of a migrant laborer ever
receiving a college diploma Harvest of
Shame was the inspiration for a program
designed to find a way to college for
the children of Migrant farmers in 1992
CBS Sunday Morning correspondent David
coolhane and reported on cameras and
caught up with migrant worker students
in the program at St Edwards University
I can't do this for the rest of my life
I've got to go to school this is what I
want to do one of the students was a
recent graduate named Geronimo Rodriguez
uptight yeah
it's the best way to put it I was kind
of scared I was proud of my degree I was
ready for whatever was going to be in
front of me he didn't even graduated
from law school became a Healthcare
Executive a school board trustee
attorney and today a mentor to New Camp
students at his alma mater the reason
that I am here is because I don't
believe in being the exception
I think we have a responsibility and
obligation to ensure that kids that have
experiences like mine that we are the
role
Justin Trevino is the son of Migrant
workers from Eagle Pass Texas and wants
to start his own video game business but
first he has to navigate life away from
home I obviously I'm nervous because you
know like you said like not familiar but
I've always been a person that strived
for more and I've always wanted to do
big things Camp mentors aren't just
helping students adjust but parents too
tensions were high when Dell's mom
almost didn't let her daughter come to
college she was worried about her safety
it was a little head budding what made
you change your mind and said go
seeing her happy
that's the only reason why she's here
because I want to see her happy
Geronimo says college is a learning
process for everyone in a migrant family
and letting go is the first lesson for
both students and parents I remember my
grandmother she would say one thing we
didn't say take care of each other
that's what I think the camp program for
me 36 years later is all about taking
care of each other for Justin and Gisele
the college assistant migrant program is
helping their family break the cycle of
poverty and harvesting Hope from my
teachers always said to never like look
at the sunset but always look at the
Sunrise so high school was a sunset but
right now when I'm starting to college
I'm looking at sunrise for CBS Saturday
morning Omar villafranca Austin Texas
uh I'm just like breathless it is take
care of each other if we did that
worldwide where would we be so many
lessons in that I mean that idea of
looking at the Sunrise looking forward
and not and the end of one chapter
starts something new but you're right
the idea that if everybody collectively
took more interest in taking care of
each other that what a difference I
think the best line was from that you
know Mom what made you change your mind
seeing seeing her happy the universal
thing for all parents and their children
moms like to see their kids and dads
yeah